hey youtubers is Charlie so the actress
that plays Lyanna Stark through this
really cool interview talking about the
Tower of joy so I'm gonna explain what
she said and what it means about that
flashback so just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen season six yet so
the actress who played Leon a stark you
might remember from the fall I actually
didn't realize it was her I've seen the
fall it's an amazing series and now that
I realized who she is on that series
it seems so apropos that she's Lyanna
stark because of the scandal that she
was caught up in Westeros with regard
Targaryen so naturally she played a very
scandalous character on the fall very
different type of scandal but the way
people inside gamer throat characters
talk about it in retrospect it was
extremely scandalous that they ran off
together
although when most of the characters
talked about it in the books and on the
TV show they make it sound like Rhaegar
kidnapped her the twist probably being
that they were in love but Lyanna stark
had been betrothed to Robert Rhaegar was
already married but there wasn't a whole
lot they could do about it so they just
decided to bail
that's for future seasons to reveal I
believe there will be more flashbacks
that'll spell that out a little bit
better but the actress whose name is
Aisling she actually said that she did
speak a sentence when she was whispering
to Ned she was like I'm not sure that I
can reveal it because I don't know which
direction they're gonna take it in
future seasons but it is an actual
sentence so what she does say that we do
hear is that Robert will kill him you
have to protect him he wouldn't
understand so right now a lot of people
like it sounds like she's telling him
who the baby's name is like Johnson oh
maybe has a Targaryen name that's really
where most of the speculation is but I
think it's a little bit broader than
that I think she's explaining the whole
situation tonight like this is what
happened we ran off together this baby
is ours please protect him so it's not
just his name that she's whispering
she's basically giving him all this
exposition and probably explaining that
no he didn't kidnap me we ran away
together we were in love but then you do
hear the part where she's like Robert
totally would not understand he will
kill the baby please promise me Ned so
it is totally possible that Jon Snow has
a Targaryen name but I don't think
that's the only thing that's happening
when she's whispering to him but of
course the TV show isn't gonna slap you
in the face was something that it's
never gonna explain so at some point in
the future next season or season 8
they'll finally reveal the rest of that
backstory but you know because season 6
was all about revealing
Jon Snow's mother I think season seven
will spell out his father a little bit
more we all know that's Rhaegar
Targaryen now so we're just gonna learn
a little bit more about him probably
through brand flashbacks but the other
cool thing about them casting Aisling
for this very specific scene because
there was a different actress in another
flashback it was a much younger version
of Lyanna stark because the tourney at
Harrenhal and this event aren't too far
apart in time she could totally play
Liana in another flashback there's just
earlier in time where she and Rhaegar
actually do meet and then choose to run
off together so I'm thinking tourney at
Harrenhal I'm thinking Night At The
Laughing tree but the actress was a
little coy when she talked about whether
or not she was coming back like she
didn't flat-out say no or yes so all I
will say is is that they would pretty
much have to use her again if they were
gonna do tourney at Harrenhal and for
those of you that are wondering about
the timeline of Eternia and Harrenhal
Robert's rebellion and Jon Snow's birth
you have to look at the books because
the tourney at Harrenhal happened in 281
AC Robert's rebellion ended in 283 AC
and this Tower of joy event happened
right at the end of that so Jon Snow
born somewhere around the end of 283
early 284 may be very fuzzy on the date
so you could just say that Jon Snow was
born right at the tail end of Robert's
rebellion you can see how it was
actually even less than three years
passed between tourney at Harrenhal
Rhaegar abducting Liana and then Jon
Snow being born so I'll be really
curious the way they paint Rhaegar and
Lyanna relationship early on just
because it sounds like if they only met
at the tourney of Harrenhal think they
would have had to have met each other
before then otherwise it's love at first
sight and then they just immediately
rush off it caused this giant scandal
which is totally possible happen but it
sounds like the way people talk about
Rhaegar he was a little more calculated
obsessed with prophecy so maybe they
made each other when they were children
and then got to know each other better
as they got a little bit older then you
get to the tourney at Harrenhal where
she was actually she would have been
about 15 or 16 years old
at the tourney of Harrenhal right about
the age that Sansa would have been when
she was forced to marry ramsay like
really close so you can see how there's
a common theme of women being married to
people when they don't want to like just
kind of being passed around so a lot of
alliances were forged through marriage
so you know naturally you could see how
in a time of relative peace Lyanna stark
who people say aria is just like
you can imagine if Aria was forced to
marry someone what she would probably do
she would probably run off to but you
can see how if she cared about someone
else like rhaegar targaryen her fell in
love with him how she would pull an aria
and just bail so I'll be really
interested to see how the show deals
with that like if it's in like a really
brief flashback that bran sees typically
they like to do things visually without
explaining it like without a lot of
talking which i think is actually a good
thing like the way they transition from
baby Jon Snow to adult Jon Snow to tell
you who the baby is
so we'll probably see crown of blue
roses but then they'll also have to
explain how they just kind of ran off
together
Robert went crazy Robert's rebellion
started and then you can go back to the
season six episodes and watch how that
all ended well let me know what you guys
think about the idea like the twist of
their relationship being that they were
actually in love and they ran off like
Rhaegar didn't force her to run off and
have this Jon Snow prophecy baby it
sounds like the way the show is treating
prophecy isn't that a lot of people talk
about it like it's a big deal but in
reality when people are actually like in
the moment making real decisions they
don't think about prophecy at all it's
all just pure emotion like when
Melisandre is resurrecting Jon Snow she
had completely given up on the idea of
prophecy
she only doubled down on it and started
calling him the one who was promised
after he was risen so for a long time
we've been talking about how Rhaegar was
obsessed with the prophecy of the prince
who was promised I wouldn't be surprised
if the show took a slightly different
interpretation when we actually see him
and it seems more of an emotional
response like I'm not really happy in my
marriage to Elia Martell yes I have a
family I'm a prince I have obligations
but I really love Leon a start and then
Lyanna stark you know adult Aria being
like I'm not super hot at being forced
into a marriage with Robert Baratheon
when I'm in love with this other person
here so they both just collectively
decide to bail and then over the course
of that year she gets pregnant nine
months later Robert's rebellion ends we
get Jon Snow so let me know if you agree
in the comments they do tourney at
Harrenhal flashback because it happened
less than three years before Jon Snow
was born they have to bring this actress
back and let me know if you think that
they'll actually spell it out pretty
clearly that they were in love and ran
off together or if they'll be really
ambiguous about it that would be a
little infuriating but I can understand
that the show didn't want to over
explain things but of course they will
eventually explain what she whispered
tonight I just I think that it's going
to be broader
just explaining what his Targaryen name
is if he has one but when you're
thinking about baby jon snow's real name
are possible real Targaryen name just
remember that babies in Westeros
typically didn't get a real name till
they were two years old
so that is why Ned later named the baby
Jon Snow he probably didn't name it John
right after he walked out of the tower
but just as a reminder big Game of
Thrones stuff happening next week
there's gonna be a comic-con panel
they're probably going to announce a few
things about next season there might be
a casting reel so be sure to subscribe
to get that video whatever they end up
doing I will totally do a video for it
the giveaway will be good next week
there's also a new round of the giveaway
that's going on right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so what's
gonna happen is is I'll do a Q&A video
in a couple days and then early next
week I'll do a Comic Con preview but if
there any other Game of Thrones videos
that you guys want me to do just let me
know in the comments why you guys wait
for me to post my next video you can
click here for the zora high video that
I just did about Jon Snow and Daenerys
about how the show is messin with the
idea of azor Ahai and you can click here
for my Suicide Squad Harley Quinn
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you